[Music]
rosemarys in Lexington Kentucky welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show rosemary hi Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up
so I unfortunately am looking at a
divorce coming down the pike here mmm I
know
we've tried to do your courses before so
I'm familiar with it but anyways so it's
I have not worked in 14 years I have had
a job for the last 7 months not making
Taunton with $12 an hour so my question
is so many people are saying I do have a
little bit of a nest egg my dad passed
away so I do have about three hundred
and sixty-two thousand dollars colder
and put away and it's a mutual fund how
old or gently I'm 50 I'll be 50 on
Friday happy birthday any kids home
Thanks
yes to 14 and 12 okay and I assume the
child support payments will be
substantial I hope yes he is in the home
right now he has no plans to leave the
home because of finances so I guess what
I don't know is do I because of finances
he doesn't want to gone what's that mean
he can we can't afford for him to leave
we cannot afford for him to have to
there's no way he can afford another
place and our home what does he might
pay the bills about 76,000 days old on
choose 32 or 521 hmm sir your questions
when do we sell oh yeah yeah
I keep the house I can't afford the
house the house is not a blessing the
only way you can afford to keep the
house just pay it off and that would use
up almost all your money no right I
don't want to do that I don't want to do
that either I don't think so
and this is a horrible thing y'all are
going through I'm so sorry and it's hard
on the kids
and moving is the thing you're not I
don't want to tell the kids I got to
move too but they do right they do
because you guys cannot afford the house
correct it needs to be sold you you
can't handle it no car payments and only
about $8,000 and debt okay what's the
debt on credit cards just like random
both of you all random credit cards both
of us on those yes so as soon as that as
a part of the divorce why don't you pay
off the credit cards
I will that was my plan and cut them up
and make sure the accounts are
completely closed so he doesn't run them
back up okay it's not a problem
mine for sure okay well then then you
cut them up so you don't run them back
out and then what you've got to do is go
rent something as cheaply as you can and
develop what you want to be your career
in the second act the curtain went down
on the first act when the curtain comes
up everybody's standing we're standing
on stage smiling and we continue with
the play okay yeah you gotta you got an
encore career here I mean there's
something you can do it wasn't what you
wanted it wasn't what you signed up for
it when how you thought this was going
to turn out but it could end up being
something really fun and lucrative might
be you need to take a few classes and
get some more tools in your belt I don't
know maybe some of your money you would
use for education but what do you want a
new business I've been working for six
months of a transaction coordinator for
a real estate company so I do contractor
clothes work for $12 an hour
no that was with them and now I'm
charging per transaction about 250 room
200 per transaction right now and you're
going on a real estate person you do
that for correct
excellent
five agents I'm hoping to get ten or
more closings a month that's my goal
right now Wow
okay I'll be twenty-five hundred you can
live on that
I can watch what you're doing okay and
you could grow this business and
actually have people working for you
that are doing it I mean this could go
really big it got some wonderful idea
okay good you got your you got your
second act right okay
you can run keel you can do it but don't
don't try to hold on to the past and you
know it's like I'm gonna hold on to this
anchor while I try to swim to the boat
correct and that's what this house is
it's going to take you down yes
maintenance and bills and electricity is
30,000 our mortgage I'll take it down so
we're gonna let you rent a little while
and not touch the 300 let it sit there
and when you get your income up forty
fifty thousand then reach over and find
you about a $200,000 house and pay cash
for it great and no debt great no debt
ever again
no credit cards ever again no car
payments over again and no - okay I'm
probably you're gonna you're gonna make
this turn it's a horrible transition but
you're gonna make it and if you need
more help you call me back as you go and
I'll walk with you
I understand how scary it is out there